we're here to give them what they want
which is someone to ask them random
questions about a topic that they least
expected we'll see who we get you guys
play chess you want to talk about it
where do you play chess at you know in
your dorm do you use any of like the
chess websites or yeah
yeah no okay when I say chess the first
word that pops into your mind
protect my queen time time yes let's
elaborate on that after time what comes
next decisions
strategy tactics tactics that's genius
okay Ivory Ivory yeah like Ivory pieces
that's a first I love that black black
love it like the the pieces black pieces
yeah yeah okay Toby Maguire oh my God
you saw Pawn sacrifice yeah I did that
was the worst chess movie ever no it is
it's all right Shelby you've really
screwed up that that was the worst right
how'd you get into chess him and him my
dad made me say chess lessons when I was
like a young kid and then then you got
your friends into chess here I got my
friends in chess because we bought a
little chess just a little chess set for
the dorm Jess you play chess good chalk
anyway chess no okay do you play chess
would you like to answer any questions
about it I feel like maybe I'm looking
unapproachable if you're on Tinder and
you're scrolling and someone has a chess
player on their profile is that swipe
left or swipe right
it's like bright is good right yeah then
yeah
I'll swiping right yeah you swiping
right you feel that do I look like I'm
on theater tinder's for everyone
everyone
neutral I'm just gonna have to say it
depends on the pictures sorry I'm sorry
uh right right yeah so you'd be into
that swiping right on that instant swipe
right okay super into that right I'm
into it you're ready okay I have a
girlfriend but I'm sweating right yeah
she's she's watching this so now she
knows very good this is all very
hypothetical but probably whatever the
swipe is I don't not interested you're
not interested in chess players I'm not
interested chess players are on Tinder
oh I get that I in fact that checks out
um I think any person who takes time out
to learn something in depth is a cool
person yeah that was deep if I ask you
to name one chess player in the world
can you name a chess player
yeah no not gonna absolutely not
absolutely not no chest part no chest
okay Gary yeah okay he's a Russian guy
yeah the Russian guy who's far off
kaspora
Anish giri yeah wow this guy's name
another one for me
um
Larson Magnus Carlson Carlson
I saw a movie uh-huh this woman yeah
this girl she played against the
Russians yeah red hair keep going red
hair come on Anna Taylor Joy okay there
you go checks out Beth Harmon for the
win capablanca wow name another one oh
Casper of Casper if you name five other
world champions in the next 15 seconds
I'm Gonna Give You fifty dollars
ski
holgar
Carlson and
on holy
dude hey dude that was awesome that guy
took my fifty dollars we played that
match versus the the Deep green like a
the Deep green computer you remember
that oh yeah vaguely yes yes yes uh blue
Something Blue Monster it was Blue
Monster IBM Blue Monster yeah Hans
Neiman not even like that American who
played the Russians in the 70s oh oh
that thing all over Tick Tock with the
guy with the with the butt you know
let's talk about Chess baby let's talk
about you and me I'm trying to look
approachable I'm not I don't bite I'm
not intimidating sorry about hey chess
chess no okay cool okay if you can play
chess against one person family member
or famous who would it be Lady Gaga just
so I can have a conversation with her
there you go that's what we need is Lady
Gaga if you're out there chess chess
with Lady Gaga you got a famous person
you want to play with uh not famous but
I think just my grandpa just your
grandpa he learned me uh to chest I
think I would probably play against
Floyd Mayweather because he I don't
think he would win yeah well he actually
plays chess yes do you have the Night
Moves
you don't okay do you know how any chess
pieces move yes okay can you show me how
one piece moves the one on the front
there go one yeah one you know what that
piece is called okay it's it's called a
pond do you know how any of the pieces
move
yes
yes okay I think I could remember how
they all move yeah The Rook okay moves
uh horizontally and vertically the horse
it moves in L's okay yeah yeah where are
you from originally uh Los Angeles Los
Angeles so all the way across the
country yeah yeah it's pretty far some
would say you actually moved like a
bishop to get here right someone say
that yeah okay anyone here know how the
night moves can you show me how the
night moves the night the night okay I
know it it's a complicated piece show us
show us do it
yeah one okay nice what about the bishop
Bishop yeah oh the bishop is diagonal
right yeah this has been amazing you
guys have been the best chess crowd we
could have ever asked for so thank you
thank you for your time okay thanks man
thank you so much Deborah for your time
that's a lovely name thank you that's
awesome thank you so much cool man it's
been awesome thank you thank you good to
meet you enjoy New York
those are the kind of fans we wanted
let's move let's all move like a knight
as we get out of here okay ready one two
over one two four one two four there you
go we did it
[Music]